تتهم جنوب افريقيا اسرائيل بالعزم على
تدمير الفلسطينيين في غزه كجزء من
المجموعه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه الاوسع كما
تتهمها بانها تقتل وتؤذي وتعمل على تدمير
سكان غزه جسديا كمجموعه وجاء في ملف
الدعوه ايضا ان اسرائيل حولت قطاع غزه الى
انقاد ولا تزال تعمل على ذلك وتشير جنوب
افريقيا الى ان اسرائيل تستخدم ما سمتها
القنابل الغبيه ودفع المدنيين للنزوح
الجماعي وطمس المؤسسات المدنيه الفلسطينيه
وتمضي جنوب افريقيا في دعواها متهمه
اسرائيل بحرمان المدنيين من الحصول على
الغذاء والماء الكافيين والرعايه الطبيه
اكثر من ذلك جاء في الدعوه ان اسرائيل
تمنع الولادات الفلسطينيه في غزه من خلال
تشريد الحوامل وحرمانهن من الرعايه وقتلهن
وتستند جنوب افريقيا في دعواها الى
تصريحات لقاده واساسه اسرائيليين فيها الى
عمليات طرد جماعي من غزه ولكي تنجح جنوب
افريقيا في اتهامها لاسرائيل بارتكاب
اباده جماعيه في قطاع غزه يتعين عليها ان
تثبت لمحكمه العدل الدوليه ان هدف اسرائيل
ليس القضاء على حماس فحسب بل القضاء على
سكان غزه بصفتهم
فلسطينيين